[Music]
in hired criminals news submitted by the
shermanator Sherman I sure many yeah
that's right
the memory of it two men hired to test
the security of a local courthouse were
arrested for breaking in why were they
arrested him they worked many times the
cops here that like oh I was I was hired
to try to test their security out like
who's gonna believe that [ __ ] yeah so
they're actually called penetration
testing protesters so pen testers so
they also have sex - I like their title
iteration testers yeah so these - your
penetration tester either my intestine
I'm a penetration abuser oh [ __ ] abusing
the process just turn I see penetrate
yes these two men they work as physical
penetration testers oh my god physical
penetration testers huh see they don't
tell you about these jobs in high school
no yeah the guidance counselor they need
to tell us about these jobs cuz they
sound pretty fun yes we work for a cyber
security company called cold fire and
they were hired to test the dallas
county courthouses our wait Iowa's
Dallas County Courthouse and to make
sure that big could not be physically
penetrated oh is this like equivalent to
like well a cooler version of like a
secret shopper you know when they come
in and then you kind of like pretend to
be customers and they sit down and do
the whole restaurant experience yeah and
then at the very end they're just like
I'm gonna get you fired
yep sounds like it secret break-in and
what are the parameters cuz if I was one
of these guys and if they just said try
to penetrate this courthouse any way you
can I would just rent a f-150 and try to
drive through it I know they're testing
the security oh so much you got to
secretly go in somehow burglar style
your your renters nightmare by the way
I'm just doing my job I will get up like
what happened to my [ __ ] truck dude
Jesus Christ get a tow truck and I'll
tie it to the bars and then [ __ ]
break the whole wall just like the
movies don't rent to these guys man [ __ ]
that that's how you have a defined job
dude we'll get through
oh yeah well leave at the [ __ ] bar
though that it's like hey I bet you
can't get through my window and Bart's
like I rented an Apache helicopter and
I'm going to [ __ ] nothing like
overkill and a bulldozer just that's a
bet though I get it yeah I mean if it in
any way is necessary right like well
okay so then be it so it turns out the
keys inconspicuously it turns out that
there they had been hired by the state
court administration not the courthouse
door like themselves so the local police
didn't even know about it so then that's
why it was meant to be secret is there
an extender but the fact that they were
able to get arrested like they got
caught got arrested but still they
they're still in jail like they being
charged so they're just like what the
[ __ ] like we're doing your dog kind of
thing there's still being trouble didn't
go oh why don't you just tell us you
were hired to [ __ ] break in so the
thing is that they have been charged
with possession of burglary tools and
third degree burglary and a fifty
thousand dollar bond is what they added
to so this county is very
miscommunicated mm-hmm they don't work
together this isn't like the end of a
movie at all mm-hmm where it just all
gets nicely wrapped up one way into the
police what's happening like I always
love that [ __ ] yeah exactly they just
like what they're like nope you still
broke the law because the thing is the
state court administration the ones who
hired them said it did not intent or
anticipate those efforts to include the
forced entry into a building that's what
they got a define what you want them to
do but I mean did they get in so there's
that yeah I succeeded they did their job
and the courthouse knows that now they
got to have better security what's in
the courthouse what can I even steal
from you like what do you mean
like people are trying to avoid jail or
something or maybe protecting the judges
they don't want the judges to get jumped
by people for the judges jewels
what are the judges jewels I mean right
now it's I'm saying there's no I mean
well like hit like he keeps their
jewelry Courthouse or like there's like
a [ __ ] a good place actually if it's
really secure secure
judges diamond what about people try to
break out and [ __ ] well yeah when they
have their court trial like only hold
them there yeah yeah yeah I wonder if
this would work let's say me and Joe
were hired to go into this courthouse I
ran a cop uniform and I rent a jumpsuit
for Joe it's orange and I had he looks
more like oh hey I never bring this guy
in for processing and they just let us
in probably like yeah he looks like a
few [ __ ] yeah take them in or we could
both be janitors and then maybe Joe is
pushing the janitor cart with the brooms
and the tissue paper and not just in a
bag that's inside the car yeah
you're here to clean the office I think
that should be reversible then you guys
go to the bathroom change in a police
outfit and then help your homie come out
or I have an idea just wear regular
clothes to you can go into a courthouse
but they're not gonna let us in we
talking about diligent during the day
well what if we have fans there we
didn't think about that they're gonna be
like a big picture damn stop [ __ ] a
routing [ __ ] probably the guards with
our fans too if you guys ever see us at
a courthouse wearing police outfits or
anything like that don't ask us for a
[ __ ] picture get out of the way yeah
we're trying to break out a friend out
of prison we show you photos of these
guys
me or Steve in prison for if I'm ever in
prison dude just hire a good lawyer
because there's no way I did it for me
it's just smacking someone that's
sleepwalking sleepwalk fighting do it
guys that's not even fair I feel bad
criminally he looks like criminal I'm
for sure he looks kind of happy look
he's happy he looks like a convict from
an Indian Reservation yeah and what
about the other one going to he looks
sad see he's the inmate and the other
guys the cop for sure yeah Bart scenario
yeah but they need other guys
play it why does nobody dress up like a
locksmith and then just break into a
courthouse or something
what is it locksmith just like they have
like those shirts with the back patches
that says locksmith so when you see me
like a sister locksmith probably
probably the judge left his keys in
there no one ever thinks to be the
flower delivery person oh that's good
that's a lot of movies yeah that is or
pizza or not at the courthouse okay
Oh what about a lawyer oh that's really
that's actually really clever
really big all right juror you could
dress like a juror you know yeah so you
either way you just wearing a suit just
walk in how do you know if you're a
juror or a lawyer you don't have you
guys ever done jury duty no yeah yeah
what is that like did you get picked I
did but then they settled it before we
had to go into the courthouse mm-hmm
dang I didn't get picked
yeah Saint I didn't get picked you
always hear people being like hey if you
bring a copy of mine comp ruin it for if
you sit there you [ __ ] read it
they're not gonna pick you for the trial
but I'm like I'm not gonna sit there for
four hours reimagine just the feeling of
having people be like this [ __ ] read
[ __ ] by a cop look at this guy I'm
sorry I'm gonna have to get picked while
you're reading it you should be laughing
- such a good point Hitler oh that would
be a pretty good way you know I think I
think that's one of those things that
it's an American beauty but no one wants
to [ __ ] do it oh wait I don't know
anybody that wants to do it my grandpa's
like that [ __ ] in the trash I don't like
this guy served in the military yeah
he's like start out the [ __ ] trash
what are they gonna do send a police
officer out here he's like I've donate
to those [ __ ] yeah things like voting
and jury duty those are the two things
as citizens we're supposed to be doing
Joe and I'm like if we hate it all I was
this close to being chosen I was like
please no no and then they [ __ ]
locked into jury before I got in so
Noel's like the next filling up yeah
can't be so zealous but these days can
you bring our phone in cuz yeah you
could be more entertained oh yeah wait
during the trial in the travels like
when you're waiting to be big no no we
don't when you're sitting in there in
the jury's can you like you know just be
like scrolling around the defeats the
purpose purpose of you being there come
on Julie trials like Dave tape it
depends on the trial McCabe it could be
a week sometimes I would me like what
would that months and months and months
maybe do when I went I was so scared
because it was like around the time that
one of those major murders happened I
was like oh my god I'm gonna get on this
[ __ ] crazy Laci Peterson style trial
where it's like forever and then you're
in the news for being a [ __ ] juror I
wouldn't mind that more than like
getting picked for like El Chapo case
and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I think I'm scary
I'll be like I've never heard of sort of
a juror on the news uniform murderer Oh
Jay Jay they come they come out later
every lote a juror has a book yeah
Michael Jackson jurors every any
celebrity case yeah they come out and
talk about their experience never well
good thing you're a news lady no I mean
it's the most boring news yeah nobody
reads that [ __ ] like I was a dog with
juror number 12 on the OJ trials like
nobody gives a [ __ ] dude well there's
like the swing jurors and stuff to the
ones that or like you know making a
murder those jurors were kind of popular
because there were ones that believed
that Steven Steven Avery didn't do it
and then yeah so their opinions were
kind of interesting but didn't they have
to have a unanimous quorum to convict
him I don't know I don't think it was
unanimous I think that it was unanimous
but then there was some jurors who had
now had second thoughts
oh or some [ __ ] yeah yeah cuz yeah there
were people that had doubts and then
they're just like well I just wanted to
get it over with I know that feeling
though cuz I think as soon as I step in
all but I would have been like guilty I
don't I want to get the [ __ ] outta
[ __ ] hungry I'm like yeah yeah look
II get guilty guilty I don't know
I'm gonna [ __ ] someone coming with the
baguette calls jr. with waffle fries
you're like get me out of here yeah or
no I'm like oh I'm you're all here mouth
especially if this person has like
several strikes ready I'm alright guilty
guilty guilty yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]